bienvenidos de nuevo vamos a seguir
resolviendo los problemas y en esta
ocasión vamos en el problema número 11
el problema número 11 tienen esta figura
que tenemos aquí y me dicen que la
circunferencia de amarillo esta
circunferencia de aquí tiene centro en
qom y por lo tanto la recta
ven es un diámetro de esta
circunferencia y bueno además tenemos
estas dos semicircunferencias esta de
aquí y estar acá estas 12.000
circunferencias tienen como diámetro
la primera y la segunda tiene como
diámetro ope y bueno me dicen que el
perímetro de esta circunferencia de
amarillo es igual a 36 speed entonces
eso déjame apuntarlo es muy importante
con color amarillo
voy a poner que el perímetro de la
circunferencia de amarillo perímetro
perímetro de la circunferencia de
amarillo es 36 spin muy bien mi
circunferencia de amarillo tiene un
perímetro de 36 pi y lo que nos
preguntan es la longitud del camino a o
b pasando por la semicircunferencias muy
bien ahora si nosotros sabemos que el
perímetro de la circunferencia de
amarillo es 36 espín entonces con esto
vamos a poder saber cuánto vale su
diámetro y cuanto al de su radio
una vez que tenemos el radio entonces
vamos a tener esta longitud y si te das
cuenta el radio de mi circunferencia de
amarillo es el diámetro de esta semi
circunferencia que pasa por los puntos
y yo y una vez que ya tengo el diámetro
de esta semi circunferencia
entonces voy a poder encontrar el
perímetro de esta circunferencia y bueno
aquellas formas de hacerlo la primera
sería tomándome perímetro completo de la
circunferencia cuyo diámetro es a om y
después dividir este perímetro entre dos
así que déjenme hacerte aquí la
circunferencia entera cuyo diámetro es
aún más o menos me va a quedar algo así
primero déjenme poner puntos ligeros de
nuez y ahorita los voy a remarcar
entonces más o menos me tiene que quedar
así y lo que voy a hacer es sacar el
perímetro completo de esta
circunferencia para que así pueda
dividirlo entre dos y después hacer
exactamente lo mismo con la
circunferencia
bueno esa es una forma de resolverlo a
sacar primero un perímetro dividirlo
entre dos saca el segundo perímetro y
dividirlo también entre dos me quedaría
algo más o menos así pues usado acaso
darnos cuenta que como es el centro de
la circunferencia de amarillo entonces
podemos cortar por aquí a esta
circunstancia y desplazarla para acá y
darnos cuenta que si nosotros nos
tomamos el perímetro de esta
circunferencia completa es exactamente
lo mismo que tomarme este pedazo de aquí
más este pedazo de acá es decir que si
unimos estos dos pedazos nos quedaría
una circunferencia completa y bueno
entonces lo primero que hay que sacar es
el radio de esta circunferencia grande
que tenemos aquí y cómo sacamos el radio
pues bueno yo sé que la forma del
perímetro de una circunferencia espn por
el diámetro o en su dado caso esto es lo
mismo que dos y por el radio entonces
vamos a sacar el radio si yo sé que el
perímetro más de 36 pin por lo tanto me
quedarían que dos mil por el radio es
exactamente igual
y 6 y muy bien y ahora que ya tengo esto
entonces cómo puedo sacar el radio de la
circunferencia de amarillo pues lo que
voy a hacer es dividir todo entre dos
pinos voy a dividir esta parte en 30 2
para esta parte entre 2 pin de tal
manera que dos pin y dos pick se van y
me va a quedar que el radio es igual
picón pisaban y 36 entre 2 me da 18 esto
quiere decir que el radio de esta
circunferencia de amarillo es 18 por lo
tanto tenemos 18 unidades de quiaca y 18
unidades de aquí acá y bueno la forma
más fácil de resolver este problema no
es tomándome este perímetro dividiéndolo
entre 2 tomándome este perímetro y
dividendo entre 2 luego me voy a tomar
todo el perímetro de esta trayectoria
completa y entonces para sacar eso lo
que voy a hacer es sacar el perímetro de
esta circunferencia que tengo aquí de
color rosa entonces para sacar este
perímetro voy a decir que el perímetro
es igual a 2 veces
por el radio o en su dado caso pin por
el diámetro y entonces lo único que hay
que hacer es multiplicar pin por 18 es
decir que esto es lo mismo que 18 pin y
este es mi resultado de este problema me
el resultado este problema
es 18 pin que es el perímetro de toda la
circunferencia completa o dicho otra
manera el perímetro de esta parte más a
esta parte entonces mi respuesta es 18
pin entonces podemos decir que esta
parte de aquí la longitud de este camino
es 9 pin mientras que la longitud de
este otro camino también va a ser 9 pi
espero no haya sido muy confuso para ti
y me hayas entendido así que vamos a
movernos a otro problema el siguiente
problema dice lo siguiente problema
número 12 muy bien tengo este problema
de aquí y me dicen que tengo una función
lineal déjame apuntarlo aquí tengo una
función lineal
y además me dan una tabla me dicen un
cierto valor de x un cierto valor para f
de x así que déjame hacerte en esta
tabla que me dan aquí a déjame agarrar
este de aquí y tengo una tabla por aquí
muy bien
el cole y qué valores me dan bueno me
dicen que cuando x vale 0 f x vale
después cuando x vale 1 fx vale 24
y cuando x vale 2 efe de x toma el valor
de b y lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale a más b
eso es lo que yo quiero saber cuánto
vale más b bueno lo primero que quiero
que recordemos es que cuando nosotros
tenemos una función lineal estamos
hablando de una recta entonces una
función lineal tenemos una línea recta y
si tenemos una línea recta entonces
tenemos una pendiente constante tenemos
siempre la misma pendiente entonces
pendiente pendiente
constante constante esto va a ser muy
útil y ya que sabemos que la pendiente
es constante entonces vamos a ver qué es
lo que pasa con la pendiente con estos
puntos sería muy bueno recordar que me
pasa con la pendiente con estos puntos
para entonces entender perfectamente
bien que podemos tomar una pendiente
constante y entonces vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar el valor de hamás bien
ahora lo primero que vamos a es tomar la
pendiente entre estos dos puntos de aquí
vamos a tomarnos la pendiente entre
estos dos puntos de aquí y después me
voy a tomar la pendiente con otro color
me voy a tomar este color y me voy a
sacar la pendiente de estos dos puntos
de aquí así que vamos a hacer lo primero
para los dos primeros puntos y yo sé que
la pendiente es exactamente igual al
cambio en james entre el cambio en x y
recuerda que fx es exactamente lo mismo
que lleva entonces lugar de fx vamos a
poner bien recuerda que es exactamente
lo mismo
hasta que primero saquemos la pendiente
de este par de puntos y para esto que me
tengo que tomar es la diferencia en jeff
es decir 24 - am
24 - am ya estoy dividirlo entre el
cambio en x es decir 1 - 0
1 - 0 y bueno esto es exactamente lo
mismo que esto de acá me da 1 y arriba
me queda 24 - entonces 24 menos a
perfecto es la pendiente de los primeros
2 puntos
ahora como sacamos la pendiente de estos
otros dos puntos pues exactamente igual
la pendiente va a ser igual al cambio en
james el camión ya va a ser de menos 24
b menos 24 ya esto lo tengo que dividir
entre el cambio en x que es 2 - 1
2 - 1 y 2 - 1 también me da 1 por lo
tanto esto es igual a menos 24 muy bien
y ahora aquí viene la parte más
importante como tenemos una función
lineal entonces tenemos una recta y como
tenemos la recta entonces tenemos una
de constante y que significa una
pendiente constante que la pendiente
siempre es la misma por lo tanto está
pendiente y está pendiente tienen que
ser iguales o dicho de otra manera
24 - am 24 - am tiene que ser
exactamente igual ap - 24
avn - 24 porque la pendiente es la misma
para cada par de puntos y que cree eso
aquí ya tengo una ecuación pero en esta
ecuación puedo trabajar la idea que si
yo paso a de este lado me va a quedar 24
es igual a más a menos 24 llevarse paso
este 24 para acá me queda que 48 es
igual a más b que es exactamente lo que
yo quería mi respuesta de este ejercicio
es 48 a más verbales 48 que es justo lo
que yo quería que por cierto es el
inciso c
muy bien ahora vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio antes de que se nos acabe el
tiempo déjenme borrar todo esto y
vámonos al siguiente ejercicio que es
nuestro problema 13 nuestro problema 13
y nos dice tenemos la siguiente sucesión
la sucesión 3 después pasa al 5 después
pasan al menos 5 muy bien además el
problema nos dice lo siguiente la
sucesión empieza en 3 y bueno eso solo
aquí empezamos en 3 muy bien y después
cada término par lo encontramos
sumándole dos unidades al término
anterior y aquí se notan tres más dos me
dan cinco entonces aquí para acá lo que
pasó fue que sumamos dos unidades
sumamos dos unidades y este es uno de
los términos pares y después nos dice el
problema y cada término impar lo
encontramos multiplicando por menos uno
el término anterior y aquí se nota que
sí es cierto porque es de 5 para menos 5
lo que hicimos fue multiplicar por menos
1 es decir que de aquí para acá lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar por menos 1
muy bien y lo que nos preguntan es cuál
es el término 55 de esta asociación
déjame apuntarlo aquí para que no se nos
olvide cuál es nuestro término me los
voy a denotar con la am 55 de esta
sucesión y bueno pueda tenemos
sucesiones de este estilo que no son
sucesiones geométricas ni aritméticas es
una sucesión que pasa al borraron
lo primero que se me ocurre es que como
nos preguntan el término 55 no es buena
forma hacerlo a mano imagínate sacar 55
términos de esta sucesión mejor vamos a
sacar algunos términos y casi siempre
este tipo de sucesiones medio raras lo
que pasa es que se repiten suelen
empezar a repetirse después de un cierto
término así que vamos a ver si
encontramos que se repite esta sucesión
de gemma cambio de color rápido y ahora
tengo que mi primer término es 3 después
sumó 2 y llegó al 5 estás de acuerdo
esto es mi término 2 entonces que me
ponerlo
esto es el primer término este es mi
segundo término y después para llegar al
tercer término como es impar hay que
multiplicar por menos uno entonces
multiplicando por menos uno voy a llegar
al menos 5 ahora mi siguiente término es
decir me termino 4 es un término par y
como es un término para lo que hay que
hacer es sumarle 2 a la cantidad de
anterior menos cinco más dos es menos
tres y ajá
creo que ya encontré un poco del patrón
ahora nuestro siguiente término es
término impar es a cinco y ya cinco lo
sacamos multiplicando por menos uno el
anterior
entonces lo multiplicó por menos uno lo
voy a encontrar que este término es 3 y
el siguiente término pues entonces hay
que sumarle 2 porque es un término par y
llegaríamos al 5 y así me puedo seguir y
seguir y seguir mi siguiente término ni
término 7 va a ser multiplicando por
menos 1 por menos 1 y entonces voy a
llegar al menos 5 y ya te estás dando
cuenta de qué es lo que está pasando
estamos encontrando un patrón
35 5 - 33 55 33 55 menos 3 y bueno ya
estoy corriendo en tiempo por lo tanto
piensa este problema y la solución de
este problema la voy a terminar de ver
en el siguiente vídeo